owning a home has long been a staple of
the American Dream and at the center of
that are two big companies Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac sound familiar maybe you
haven't thought that much about them
since the 2008 financial crisis the
federal government is stepping into it
to stabilize Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac
the two companies almost collapsed under
the weight of an unprecedented housing
bust but then the government stepped in
to bail them out now the Trump
administration has asked her plans to
reshape Fannie and Freddie but a housing
finance overhaul could mean privatizing
or shrinking the two companies a process
that some believe could mean mortgages
will become more expensive and less
affordable for millions of Americans
that includes the most popular home loan
in the u.s. the 30-year fixed-rate
mortgage homeowners like this mortgage
because of the low monthly payments and
the interest rate that doesn't fluctuate
we'll explain but first you have to
understand how Fannie and Freddie fit
into the u.s. housing system first home
owners borrow money from banks or other
lenders then Fannie and Freddie buy
these mortgages and package them into
securities then they sell those
securities to investors investors buy
them because they're considered safe
because Fannie and Freddie take on much
of the risk lenders and banks benefit
too since the government takes on much
of the default risk lenders can make
more loans to more people together
Fannie and Freddie now back about half
of new US mortgages so why do some want
to change the two companies
some in Washington want to shrink or
even get rid of Fannie and Freddie and
President Trump himself has indicated
that he wants to roll back the
government's involvement in the two
companies which have been under
government control since the financial
crisis but a housing finance overhaul
could mean privatizing or shrinking the
two companies those looking to shrink
Fannie and Freddie argue that the
government shouldn't be involved in the
housing market to the extent it is now
they say to the private sector not the
government should be filling this role
but those who support Fannie and Freddie
say that a home ownership is a path to
prosperity for the middle class and that
the government has a responsibility to
keep housing affordable but now some are
wondering what would the US housing
market look like without Fannie and
Freddie well to start with many non-bank
lenders might find it harder to operate
unlike banks these firms don't have
deposits which means it will be more
expensive for them to lend money and
Fannie and Freddie go away these so
called non-bank lenders make up about
half of new u.s. mortgages today and
they're often the only path that
first-time borrowers or middle-income
families have for getting a mortgage
that's because in the last decade many
banks have focused largely on wealthy
borrowers for making mortgages and the
non banks have moved in to fill the
space they left
beyond that no one's really sure what
the market would look like without
Fannie and Freddie but let's consider
other countries which don't operate
their housing markets like the US does
in many countries long-term fixed-rate
home loans including the 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage aren't largely
available instead mortgage rates reset
depending on the market and even a
one-point increase in your mortgages
interest rate can add hundreds of
dollars to your monthly payment we can
also look at the US before Fannie was
created in 1938 back then borrowers had
to come up with much larger down
payments often 50% or more mortgages
also tended to last for just five or ten
years with a big balloon payment that
came due at the end so future mortgages
could look like this or not at all much
of it depends on how the government
plans to reshape Fannie and Freddie
but reshaping them won't be easy people
like the benefits they create including
the 30-year fixed-rate mortgage and
right now there isn't much agreement on
either side of the aisle on how to get
rid of the government's involvement in
housing at least not without completely
overhauling the way the housing system
works so for now Fannie and Freddie's
future is still up in the air